how to report a paired samples t-test
according to APA style first of all what
is a paired t-test a paired samples
t-test tests whether there is a
difference between two paired samples
but how to report a paired t-test
reporting a PRT test according to APA
style requires presenting key statistics
in a clear concise manner here's a
general guideline on how to report the
results in six steps finally I'll show
you how to automatically create the
interpretation of your data number one
descriptive statistics Begin by
presenting the means and standard
deviations for each group example before
the intervention participants had a mean
score of m equal to
50.20 SD equal to 10.15
and after the intervention m equal to
55.30 SD equal to
9.85 number two t statistic report the T
value degrees of freedom and p-value
example a paired samples t-test revealed
a significant difference between the two
time points T28 equal to
6.50 P smaller than
0.001 T 28 represents the T value
followed by degrees of freedom in
parenthesis P smaller than
0.001 is the p-value adjust this
according to your results for example P
equal to
0.045 P equal to
0.25 and so on and so forth number three
effect size is recommended to include an
effect act size such as Cohen's D this
provides the readers with an
understanding of the magnitude of the
difference example the effect size for
the difference was large D equal to
0.90 for the interpretation of the fact
size you can use this table number four
confidence interval if applicable or if
it provides added value to your report
you can include a 95 confidence interval
for the difference between means example
the 95 confidence interval for the mean
difference ranged from
4.00 to 6.20 number five interpretation
follow the statistics with the playing
language interpretation of what the
results mean in the context of your
study example thus the intervention had
a significant influence events on
participants scores whether the
difference is significant or not depends
on whether the calculated p-value is
smaller or larger than a specified
significance level the significance
level is usually five percent if the
p-value is less than 0.05 there is a
significant difference otherwise not
number six graphs and tables while not
always necessary visual aids like bar
graphs or box plots can be helpful in
visually representing the data if you
use them ensure that they are clearly
labeled and referenced in a text tables
should be formatted according to apa
guidelines and here is a complete
example before the intervention
participants had a mean score of m equal
to 50.20 SD equal to 10.15 after the
intervention the mean score was m equal
to
55.30 SD equal to
9.85 the mean difference between the pre
and past interventions course was m
equal to
5.10 SD equal to 2.30 a paired samples
t-test indicated a significant
difference in a scores following the
intervention T28 equal to 6.50 P smaller
than 0.01 the effect size for this
difference was large with Cohen's D
equal to
0.90 the 95 confidence interval for the
mean difference ranged from 4.00 to 6.20
thus the intervention had a significant
effect on participants scores of course
when you calculate a pair t-test online
with data tab the summary inverse is
automatically generated for you just
copy your data into this table select
your variables click on t-test for
paired samples and click on summary in
words
remember when writing up your results
aim for clarity and precision ensure
that someone reading a report can easily
understand the statistical analysis
you've conducted and the implications of
the findings
thanks for watching and I hope you
enjoyed the video